hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to a coward's debt we
just ran into the monster again and then
died a horrible death I have seen that
much of the monster and I need not see
any more because I never ever ever want
to see him again that is literally the
most scared I've ever been playing
amnesia that was amazing the last part
I've been recording this all in
succession if that is even the right
word for this appropriate situation but
I've been playing all of these episodes
in a row because I'm prepping for my
trip but good god I swear I have never
been that terrified playing this game
you still locked cuz that's where I
originally heard the noise and I was
wondering if something was eventually
gonna pop out of there but it seems that
maybe not can I get in here again why is
it covered in blood but apparently I
cannot I don't know if anything changed
here or if it's all still the same okay
that's so they're dark in there I just
need to go to the way Todd all do I need
to activate the things long II wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute okay
well thank you thank you guys lady thank
you kind lady for being awesome are you
my wife did I kill you thank you for
your help you've been great in the
assistant of me okay am I going down
again please tell me I'm not going down
you don't even know why I went down I
guess I should get the master bedroom
key which I still have here and also
have the key to the office safe daddy
ever opened the office safe I don't even
remember if I did that okay there you
are
is that what you look like
I saw a head but I know there's a body
attached that that's pitch black and
works very well for the pitch blackness
ooh this game just like my soul just
like my lovely lovely lovely lovely
heart
okay so I'm on the third floor now who's
I'm sure is gonna be fun I'm never gonna
see that monster again goody goody
gumdrops I'm so happy about that why
doesn't my mansion have a staircase to
the third floor goodbye thank you once
again for abandoning me on your dad
Booya
who does that who's doing what why who
said that
why hello someone there someone wanna
not collect on my dad and maybe go away
forever Guillermo
Guillermo del Toro oh why does it have
to be dark again okay let's think happy
thoughts
butterflies unicorns rainbows pretty
pretty pretty gumdrops
am I just unlocking everything or is
everything actually unlocked because I
hear unlock noises uncertain things okay
oh did it get darker like I know when
something's troubling you yeah you can
tell I don't exam sorry my love I'm too
ashamed to speak of it a coward maybe
you are a decent woman as I know you are
then you will what did i do what did i
do before my supposed suicide what have
I done why can't just be like like
people stabbed in business people stab
each other in the back all the time and
they cheat them out of their profits and
whatever and money swindling and all
that but there must be something more to
it that I'm missing more to this mystery
like I was saying before there is some
great part of having an element of
mystery in these horror games like
combine the story in the mystery into
one so that you get this whole
experience that allows you to truly
become immersed in the game like every
time I play a horror game I usually say
the word immersion at least once
immersion is so important
hello I am unlocking that
and you are Leo you're like okay this
was a mistake but forgotten but I never
did
every minute of every day I contemplate
my revenge okay so did you kill my wife
okay well this has been a fun reunion
but could you leave my door forever and
go away did you somehow give me my mure
madness or did you oh wait a minute he
was a chemist that created a lot of
concoctions so maybe he concocted a
little something-something that was
gonna make me mad maybe he made me think
that I was losing my mind
maybe he caused me to slip into the
other world of death and dreams maybe
I'm just getting a little through poetic
here and maybe it's something much more
simple he's still out there hello
somebody there hello did something
change this is not where I once was I
close in just gonna close that door
there so no one ever comes through it
ever again where the hell am I and why
can I not see anything uh I know they
did the no Lantern thing on purpose that
doesn't mean I have to like it I know
I'm not supposed to like it I know it's
supposed to add this element of no
where are you who is way this way which
way do I go where do I go to get away
from you how do I not face you coward I
am a coward I am a very big coward
coward I am
sorry phone I don't have time to answer
you right now I'm in a bit of a
situation here as a crisis going on and
I need to get to the bottom of it no
matter what I'm oh hey hey piggy piggy
how you doing you look good I haven't
seen you in a while okay am i hmm I
don't know I don't know anymore
I don't know anything of anything about
anything all I know is that I'm about to
die if I'm not already dead whose are
those where are you hiding no where are
you bashing on the head what's going on
here Noor God why do you keep making me
think I'm making a mistake every time I
open a door I want to think that I'm
very very confident in the choices that
I make I'm causing you to doubt myself
game very much so okay nice humming in
my ears what is going on here ah this
must be the master bedroom
yay okay no no no huh oh yeah what are
you
yeah great
go ahead thank you
sounds good thank you okay I'm glad this
is all going just as you planned
horribly why don't I know that every
time I am alive I need to die that is
exactly how this game goes that's some
ending somber music well now I know the
mystery
I don't know what can I do I know what I
do I don't know what to do no I do where
do I go my stuck endlessly to be dead if
I'd buy that dude there was still a lot
of doors that were not open about where
am I going
um what do it why do I hear a ding dong
that like a child's toy
oh that's locked - okay is everything
gonna be locked except where I'm
supposed to go hopefully that'll help me
get to where I need to go sooner but I
do not know this for a fact
hello is someone standing out there in
the darkness of these windows watching
me hokey forgot how dark it was hello me
I'm an old man apparently and a key word
okay that's still locked I'm surprised
about that how I saw something would
have come out of that cuz that's the
first place I heard a noise any sort of
noise that gave any sort of indication
that there was something wrong here okay
you can still redeem yourself okay how
how do I do that
you gonna tell me you gonna tell me lady
cuz right now right now you were just
stringing me along trying to show me how
bad of a person I am I didn't kill my
wife
and I couldn't bear the shame if I had
only done something if I only hadn't
been so greedy as a Frenchman I should
have more honour
that wasn't an insult to the French I
was a very honor roll people
hello is this something trying to kill
me here I will protect her with all of
my loins everything of me shall be
dedicated to her protection
how do I does that though I I don't
really know in facing what I need to do
maybe I made the mistake by excellently
running out the back door do you really
want to watch your diet
no will you save her there's no time
left Shawn okay okay
God some of these doors or pulls in sums
or pushes no all God okay was that was
uh was that what I was supposed to do
the first time
Evangeline my love huh I will never
forget the sound of your voice mmm or
the songs of your violin mmm the shine
of the Morning Sun on your hair hmm
you showed me such love and passion far
more than I deserved
I am sorry your I could have saved you
but my cowardice held me back
oh I allowed you to die while I lived
hmm I'm sorry my love I was not worthy
of you I wish to be a decent man but it
was only a lie I can only pray that you
have gone to a better place than I given
everything may I be deserving to meet
you there hmm
I did not think you had it in you John
you've grown far beyond what I expected
hmm you overcame a great fear fear that
bested you in life hmm of course life is
short
Oh your punishment however is eternal ah
Oh God not again not again with the
waking up in the same place oh good good
idea there was much work to be done
you must get Oh oh my god this so cool
the gods had condemned SIF Sisyphus to
ceaselessly rolling Iraq to the top of
the mountain whence the stone would fall
back of its own weight they had thought
forth for some reason that there is no
more dreadful punishment than futile and
hopeless labor anyway that was awesome
now is probably one of the best custom
stories I have ever played the story was
great um I kind of had an idea what was
going on in the story either way as it
went through but that's just cuz I'm so
smart and I'm able to solve these
mysteries very elegantly but either way
that was a really fun custom story and
utterly terrifying like some of the
moments in there were the most scared
I've ever been and it was a long
build-up through the first episode but
and I wish it would have been a little
longer but I feel like it almost you
know it kind of fit it's neat it told
the story and nothing more like it
didn't have anything that was just like
dragging on longer just for the sake of
gameplay it actually was very good and I
really really liked that game a lot
thank you so much for everybody for
watching thank you developer the game
I'm just gonna get out of this just in
case
soon the
that the credit music may not be you
know royalty-free or something just
issue that youtubers have to go through
but either way that was a phenomenal and
major custom store I recommend everyone
played that there may be an easter egg
or something that I haven't found if you
have another idea let me know in the
comments below I really hope you enjoyed
this one and remember there's so many
other endings and custom stories that I
played I'll put like a huge list of all
of them down in the description below
but either way thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
chill